Hearings continue today for the Council’s draft Long Term Plan.
And Waimakariri District Councillors say they are pleased with the amount and quality
of feedback they’re receiving from the community.
We've got 60 submissions that we're listening to
verbally over the next few days
out of over 800 that have been put in.
So it's really good to hear from people
firsthand of what they're thinking and
to be able to ask some questions around
that process.
The verbal submissions
are very important as we see face to face
with the people that want to come
along to council and have their issues
that they wish us to listen to and that
is so important for us to hear their side
of the story and it helps us make our
decision in a way that we need to.
Verbal submissions will be completed today, Councillors will then consider all the
feedback from the consultation process and go into deliberations from May 29th to 31st.
Formal adoption of the LTP is expected to take place at a Council
Meeting on the 19th of June and we’ll let you know of the
key decisions made as they take place.